now
there's a receiver who has only one 100
yard receiving game this year his name
is emmanuel sanders emmanuel sanders
traded to the san francisco 49ers mds
just one day after coach kyle shanahan
suggested there's not much urgency this
year to upgrade at the position i
interpreted that as you can't come off
as desperate if you're trying to be a
buyer at the trade deadline here we are
with a week to go and may be sparked by
the muhammad sanu trade from atlanta to
new england it's emanuel sanders a guy
we knew was on the trade market he goes
from denver to san francisco and it's
sanders plus a five
for
a third round pick and a fourth round
pick from san francisco
and
ultimately
the four and the five maybe not all that
far apart because denver stinks so it'll
be a high five the 49ers are good so
it'll be a low four
so it's really a straight up three
almost
for emmanuel sanders when the patriots
gave up a second round pick to get
mohamed sanu
and i look i'm not shocked by this
but my guess is the 49ers if they were
going to make a move they'd rather have
muhammad sunu because he knows the kyle
shanahan offense he was in the shanahan
offense in atlanta when shanahan was
there as offensive coordinator
yeah i would bet that maybe the 49ers
got a little desperate when the patriots
pulled the trigger and the falcons
agreed on that sinew trade and it
wouldn't be surprising to know
that you know a lot of the time when we
talk about trades we say oh why why did
that team give up that much they they
could have gotten them for less right
but you never know what other offers are
out there
and uh you know it wouldn't be
surprising if maybe the 49ers were
dragging their feet just a little bit
on this new trade and the falcons just
said
best offer we've gotten is a two we're
ready to do it let's take the two before
you know something happens that you know
the patriots acquire some other wide
receiver like emmanuel sanders and now
they're not offering us a two anymore um
so so i found that pretty interesting
and yet you know the 49ers and the
patriots
probably the two best teams in the
league right now anyway uh it's very
interesting that they're both making
moves to try to make themselves better
and we've still got another week to go
before this trade deadline won't be
surprising if we see more of the
contenders
try to get some good players off more of
the teams that aren't going anywhere
especially because we now know more
about the teams that aren't going
anywhere last weekend's games this
weekend's games you combine the two and
you really can get to a level of comfort
after eight weeks
as to who's going to stink and who could
benefit from
using their current assets guys who may
not be there for the turnaround next
year use them now to get draft picks
that will help you get better the
falcons obviously know they stink and
the broncos after thursday night's
putrid performance offensively against
the chiefs and defensively they weren't
much better the broncos can come to the
conclusion it's time for them to sell as
well and it'll be interesting to see who
else is available from that denver team
chris harris jr cornerback in the last
year of his contract that's going to be
the next guy to keep an eye on and i
still think von miller can be had the
question is what will it take i don't
buy it anytime anyone says so and so
won't be traded o.j howard buccaneers
tight end won't be traded well if
somebody makes them an offer they can't
refuse o.j howard will be traded if the
broncos get an offer they can't refuse
for von miller von miller will be traded
now you can say generally no but
the end result may be yes and that's
part of the game that you have to play
in order to get the best value same
reason kyle shanahan says we're not
having that same sense of urgency we've
had in the past to get a receiver at the
trade deadline you say that to pay less
you say that you're not going to trade
the guy to get more and look at the
activity we've already had we still have
a full week four o'clock eastern next
tuesday is when that window closes and
there could be a lot of activity
although who knows maybe all the trades
will be done by then and there'll be
nothing left to do
yeah and and i really think when a team
puts out word like oh von miller
definitely won't be traded
i think what that actually means is
if you want von miller call us up with
an offer like two first round picks like
we've seen
jalen ramsey laramie tunsil it
that's really what they're communicating
it's not don't call us at all it's
be ready to offer us something really
good if you want us to talk about ivan
miller trade because uh
any player
can be traded for the right offer if
it's a good enough offer
any player can be traded now i i guess
there might be some franchise
quarterbacks who a team
just would say listen we're just not
interested but you know even a franchise
quarterback
if you got enough first-round picks in
in exchange for him maybe you'd think
about it so i i really believe that that
any player can be traded and certainly
von miller could be traded the real
question is is there a team that thinks
we are one good pass rusher away from
winning the super bowl if so
that team might call up with one of
those two first round picks and more
type of offers and von miller could move
yeah last week in the aftermath of the
jalen ramsay trade he harvested two
first-round picks and a fourth-round
pick for the jaguars we had some
conversations about guys you wouldn't
trade for two ones and a four and there
really aren't many guys that you would
say no way in hell to two ones and a
four the question is how many guys truly
are untouchable and
if a team is willing to put enough on
the table and those draft picks are
viewed as as so valuable for what they
mean a first round pick is five years at
a very relatively low rate in comparison
to free agent market value that it's
hard to say no when that opportunity
arises and we'll see if somebody at the
top end of the nfl's hierarchy right now
decides they want to make a run at a guy
like von miller or oj howard or other
guys that we've been told aren't
tradeable and aj green is the guy to
watch now at the receiver position
because he was the original receiver
that we were watching saying well surely
the patriots will make a play for him
and maybe the packers now will make a
play for him but if mohammed sunu is
worth a second round pick now i don't
know how healthy aj green is but i think
if sunu is worth a two a healthy aj
greens worth at least a first round pick
and maybe the patriots tried to get aj
green for a first round pick but bengals
looked at and said well it's a low first
round pick so we're not interested
yeah and the aj green situation is a
little different because he's in his
last year of his contract sunu has one
more year so
teams if you're gonna trade for aj green
i think you're either saying to yourself
we already know we're gonna franchise
him or you've talked to him and you've
gotten
if not a new deal worked out you at
least you and him and his agent at least
have a pretty good understanding of what
it'll take to get a deal done but yeah i
would agree i mean aj green is once he
gets healthy he's clearly a better wide
receiver than muhammad sunu better than
emmanuel sanders so it's going to take
something pretty good to get him but
again
the bengals of course if someone offers
them a first round pick for aj green i
think they have to do it
i think part of the problem here is it's
hard to get to the point where you're
comfortable trading for aj green and
signing aj green because he hasn't
played this year he had that injury
early in training camp no one's seen him
on a field i think recently both the
bengals and green have been going easy
on putting him back on the field because
the bengals want to be able to get trade
value green wants to leave or at least
wants to wait until he sees where he's
going to be a lot of moving parts to
make it work and you really have to take
a leap of faith if you're a new team
signing aj green to a long-term deal
because there's a chance he's not going
to be the guy that he was you may be
getting someone who is damaged good so i
think that makes it more difficult as
well so that's where the trade market
currently stands again another week to
go maybe a lot more activity as the
teams that are at the top try to go all
in and the teams at the bottom realize
that it's time to fold the tents and
live to fight another day with more
draft picks as opposed to veteran
players who won't be there when and if
things turn around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports